bill malugin has covered the Border more
closely than any reporter in the United
States for the last two years and today
in his estimation the single largest
Caravan of illegal aliens flowing into
this country in his two years of
watching crossed today he broke the
story he's got remarkable video for us
he's live at the border now Bill great
to see you what did you see
Tucker good evening to you you mentioned
it right off the top this was easily the
biggest group we have ever seen during
our 19 months of covering this border
crisis and they all crossed illegally
into El Paso last night and we got some
pretty wild camera footage to show you
take a look at this this was last night
in El Paso a massive Caravan of over 1
000 illegal immigrants Crossing into El
Paso last night local media there
reporting it was potentially up to 2 000
people and that it was possibly the
biggest Mass Crossing in the city's
history now as you look at the video
you'll see just wave after wave after
wave of these people walking across the
river and then gathering on the U.S side
of the river where they kind of form a
single file line and you'll see that
single file line starts stretching
almost as far as the eye can see as
again well over a thousand people
crossed there and it was cold there last
night so you'll see many of them started
setting campfires in an effort to keep
warm and CBP sources tell Fox News that
over the last 24 hours in that sector in
El Paso there have been more than two 2
400 illegal Crossings border patrol
there has more than five thousand
migrants in custody right now they're
completely overwhelmed completely over
capacity so they've started mass
releases of these people they're just
dropping hundreds of them off at a time
an El Paso City street so the question
here where did all these people come
from we'll show you they were bused in
with a Mexican police escort take a look
at the second piece of video here Fox
News on scene in ciudad Juarez has about
20 of these migrant buses filled with
these migrants received a Mexican police
escort into ciudad Juarez the city
directly across from El Paso and then
they were all dropped off at local
shelters and ngos there in Juarez but of
course they didn't stay at those
shelters they all started walking over
to the river walking to the border and
as you can see from the video they
started Crossing in Mass bizarre to see
the Mexican Government essentially
escorting them there to have them cross
just a few minutes later and back out
here live Tucker the numbers just
exploding here at our Southern border
with the U.S border Patrol Chief saying
in the last 48 hours there have been
more than 16
000 illegal Crossings averaging out to 8
000 per day send it back to you
biggest crime of our lifetimes Bill
mujin thanks so much